what's in here what does it do and can I
make it from scratch pick the stuff is
on your stuff ingredients dry erase
markers are magical
I mean you write on a smooth hard
surface like this dry erase board or a
mirror and then whatever you write is
almost 100% erasable without using any
liquids this is insane now normally this
is the part of the show where I take the
product package turn it around and show
you the ingredients list and as you can
see no ingredients list and this is not
just for dry erase markers office
products in general don't usually have
ingredients on the back so figuring out
how this stuff works is gonna be a job
for curious chloride Chemical detective
at Lourdes that makes no sense well
there are no chemical names that rhyme
with detective change back luckily we
have these these are MSDS Azure material
safety data sheets now companies are
required to keep these on hand for any
product or substance that an employee
might have some sort of safety concern
about now if you have no life like I do
and wade through all 40-plus MSDSs of
all the dry-erase brands not just this
one you will find one that is helpful so
let's take a look at this more detailed
ingredients list ok I don't really care
so much about the pigments what I want
to know is how does the mixture of
alcohols octa decanoic acid Tri aster
chemically modified polyvinyl alcohol
and hexanoic acid blah blah ester come
together to make a dry erasable ink
except the thing is if you look these
ingredients up online you will either
find that they have a bajillion listed
uses or none now normally this is where
I would turn to the scientific community
for help but no one seems to be doing a
ton of research on how dry erase markers
work I guess they have better things to
do the dry erase marker companies have
probably done all this work but all that
information is proprietary so what do we
do patents yep turns out there is one
key patent that explains the whole thing
basically dry erase ink is a mixture of
five different things solvent resin
pigment release agent and wax and the
wax we can ignore for now because it's
kind of a wild card the resin and the
pigment you can think of as one thing
the point of the resin
is to help the pigment evenly spread
across the surface so our simplified
system is actually three things solvent
resin pigment and release agent and the
magic is something that you probably
slept right through in high school
solubility you choose the ingredients
based on whether they do or don't
dissolve in each other so when the dry
erase marker is just sitting there on
the table the solvent has to fully
dissolve both the resin pigments and the
release agent but when you write on a
whiteboard that solvent is going to
evaporate leaving only the resin pigment
and the release agent and this is the
key part the resin pigment has to not
dissolve in the release agent so on the
whiteboard they separate out into two
layers just like oil and water the
release agent is the layer closest to
the board and the resin pigment is on
top of that but it does not stick to the
board so when you wipe the resin pigment
comes right off and the release agent
can come off too or it can stay on the
board as long as it's colorless good god
man that's brilliant and from what I can
tell the biggest difference between a
dry erase marker and a permanent marker
is that the permanent marker does not
have a release agent so here the resin
pigment just sticks to whatever you're
writing on and you cannot get it off
without some sort of solvent now what
about that wax well it turns out that's
another bit of genius if you leave the
marker sitting out like this for a long
period of time the wax is supposed to
form a thin film on the outer surface of
the tip that prevents solvent from
evaporating then when you go to write on
the board again friction between the tip
and the board breaks up the wax and lets
the ink flow okay so that's it we're
done
nope because even though we have a
general idea of how dry erase inks work
we don't know if it makes sense given
the exact chemicals in our MSDS but as
curious chloride would say let's find
out so first up are the alcohols ethyl
alcohol and isopropyl alcohol
now if you've guessed that these are the
solvents you are 100% right because
they're used in other products as
solvents and they're actually also
listed in the patent as potential
solvents so well dot ah
next up chemically modified polyvinyl
alcohol now that
a bit of a mystery but if you look it up
by ID number online you will find that
it's also called polyvinyl beuter l and
that is listed in the patent as a resin
so we're good on solvents and resin next
up hexanoic acid to ethyl hexa deckle
ester now this is where things get
complicated because the patent says you
can use an ester made from an acid with
12 to 22 carbons and an alcohol with 1
to 5 carbons do not worry about that at
all it's not important the point is hexa
decanoic acid blahblah ester almost
fulfills that almost but it's close
enough so I'm going to say that is our
release agent which might leave you
thinking that octa decanoic acid tri
aster is our wax except it's not a wax
it's not even remotely similar to wax
it's much more similar to an emulsifier
found in peanut butter than a wax so we
found our solvent our resin and our
release agent but instead of a wax we
found what I think is an emulsifier so a
couple things could be happening here
either they just say to hell with the
wax we're not going to use it or maybe
the release agent also acts as a wax but
needs an emulsifier to stay in solution
I'm afraid we will never know unless one
of you cares to enlighten us in the
comments now that we have a decent idea
of what's in dry erase markers and how
they work I'm gonna try and make my own
from scratch using only natural
ingredients so I've got ethanol acetone
and cetyl alcohol all three of which you
can get from nature I also have this
blue ink which honestly I have no idea
if it's natural or not I just had it
lying around the house so I'm going to
use it now given the detective work we
had to do to figure out what's in dry
erase ink I'm reasonably sure this
recipe is going to fail completely but
you know what that's the way science
works sometimes so let's just roll in it
here we go
I'm going to stir this and we didn't
actually heat it that much so I think I
think we can go ahead and test this
right now now I'm going to use some
paper towel as a makeshift felt tip
marker here and I'm going to write on
the board here we go
okay now moment of truth
there we go ah no actually hey wait a
second guys that's not bad I mean I
definitely left some smudgy smudge on
the dry erase board but a lot of this
ink came off on my petal I am I am NOT
disappointed with this this is a six out
of ten this is solid work especially for
a first attempt I bet if I added a
little bit more subtle alcohol I'd leave
even less of a smudge so overall I'm
happy with that I really am
if you guys have ideas on how to improve
the recipe let me know in the comments
or hit me up on Twitter and if you have
an idea for another episode definitely
let me know okay
good job detectives well done yes okay
good
yeah haha why where what have I done